two days after Hurricane Maria slammed
into Puerto Rico people are still being
rescued a British military helicopter
pulled three people to safety from the
top of a capsized boat they had made a
distress call as the hurricane hit
Maria is passing the Turks and Caicos
Islands this morning as a category 3
hurricane all of Puerto Rico is still
without power and may have no
electricity for months to come
David beg no is in San Juan where the
governor says the territory's death toll
has now risen to 13 David good morning
good morning there's a report from
Puerto Rico's largest newspaper saying
that three sisters were killed in a
mudslide that swept them away a fourth
sister was able to run away and call for
help
amid this debris and under the cover of
darkness crews worked through the night
to rescue people who have no way of
calling for help because the
communication grid is down and then
there are those people still living in
their homes too grateful to complain the
only night lights in Puerto Rico were
the lamp lights of more than three
million people living in darkness with
no electricity or running water families
in cataneo grilled their food in groups
just outside the Gonzales home this baby
girl slept in a hammock hot and humid
inside the family huddled around a
flashlight why is it that I've not seen
anyone around here complain about their
situation
because we are a small town we are
really humble people and we are grateful
for the chance we have to live another
day when I'm watching a few miles west
of here in Toa Baja at least 200 people
are staying at a shelter with limited
beds but these women are making sure no
one here is hungry Lesley Santino
Rodriguez manages the shelter I mean in
addition to giving people food she said
we must also give them hope earlier in
Toa Baja Puerto Rico's National Guard
moved quickly to get this 83 year old
woman to a hospital rescues like this
are becoming routine as the once vibrant
island is paralyzed by floodwater people
looking for help piled into the back of
military trucks others help themselves
trudging through waist-deep water in an
attempt to reach drier ground despite
the devastation there are those moments
of joy like when these brothers were
reunited for the first time since the
hurricane hit ever since President Trump
approved Puerto Rico's federal disaster
declaration we've noticed more agents
from femur here that's the Federal
Emergency Management Agency and Charlie
we just found out that at the airport in
San Juan today they're gonna start some
commercial flights but on a limited
basis and only to the US and to these
specific cities Miami Atlanta John F
Kennedy in New York and Philadelphia
David Beck no in Puerto Rico thank you
David